Dr Rand earned his phd from Harvard
University and systems biology and his Ba
from Cornell University
in computational biology.
His work focuses on human
cooperative behavior.
His approach combines
empirical observations from
behavioral experiments with
predictions generated by evolutionary
game theoretic math models and computer
simulations.
By doing this doctor ran ass.
What prosocial and antisocial decisions
people make in particular situations and
social environments.
The cognitive mechanisms that determine
how these decisions are actually made
and the ultimate explanations for why our
decision making processes have come to
function as they do.
He draws on methodologies from psychology
as well as economics and evolutionary
biology and is interested in applications
including law management and public
policy.
Dr Ran has published in high impact
journals including nature and science,
was named wired magazine's smart list,
uh,
in 2012 as one of 50 young
people who will change the world.
And his work has widely appeared
in the media, including the BBC,
NPR morning edition marketplace and all
things considered scientific American
Huffington posts, a New York
Times, La Times, the Atlantic,
The Washington Post, and Msnbc
among many others. Today,
I'll be speaking with Dr. David
Rand from Yale University. Hi, Dave.
Thanks for speaking with us today.
Uh,
my greatest pleasure.
So, Dave, um,
I think what I'd love to hear from you
is just a little bit about what first got
you interested in the topic of emotion.
So maybe you could tell us a little bit
about what took you to that path. Um,
and you know, what, what do you
think really sparked your interest?
So the way that I came to all of this
is maybe a little bit of traditional,
which is that I, um, I kind of
came out of experimental economics,
uh,
and an econ.
There's this huge focus on rationality
as like the key and center of everything.
Um, and I'm particularly interested
in pro social behavior, cooperation,
altruism kind of stuff. And it
was pretty clear to me that, uh,
rationality with not the only thing
or even perhaps the main thing,
I'm motivating a lot of
decisions in that domain.
So as I try and understand more and more
how people actually make decisions in
the context of how they each other,
uh,
it became clear that sort of intuitive
automatic processes were really important
of which emotions are a big company.
Excellent.
So what's really neat about your work,
and I would love to ask you some questions
now about your research is that it
really,
um,
working on cooperation takes this really
awesome interdisciplinary approach.
I mean, you draw and
methodologies from psychology,
economics and evolutionary biology,
which is a really unique perspective.
I don't think that anyone to date has
really taken to look at the role of
cooperation and, and how it relates
to emotion. So in humans, you know,
you found that are more quick moving and
intuitive instincts are to be where are
more slow moving or reflective responses
are actually to be more self focused or
selfish.
And I wondered if you could tell us all
just a little bit more about the studies
that you've been doing in this vein.
Yeah, so, uh,
we did a bunch of experiments using um,
economic games.
So the sort of thing where
you create a [inaudible],
the key of sort of cooperation is
situations where there's a tension between
what's individual,
what's best for the individual and
what's best for the group as a whole.
So using these economic games you do
things like everybody gets some money,
they choose how much to keep for
themselves and how it to contribute to the
group.
We're,
all of the contributions get doubled
and then split equally by everyone.
So if everyone contributes,
everyone is better off. But uh,
you personally would lose
money on contributing.
So the best thing for you
would be everyone else
contributes and you just free
ride off of that as soon as they create
this tension. And then we look at, uh,
you know, what happens when people have
to make actually make their decisions.
And what we find is what you were saying
that it seems like the automatic sort
of first response, intuitive decision
is to contribute a lot and then, uh,
the longer you think about it,
the more selfish you get. And so,
um, the correlational evidence,
we have manipulation studies.
You force people to respond quickly.
They contribute more,
you prime them to be more
intuitive, they contribute more. Um,
and I think the other thing that I want
to say about it is that it's a little
bit of a simplification to say that,
uh,
we are intuitively cooperative,
um,
in the following sense is that what we
find is basically the people's intuitions
reflect the social world that they
come from. So people that, uh,
experience like the world is a
trustworthy place where their interaction
partners are nice to
them and stuff like that.
Their automatic reaction
is to be cooperative.
People that come from a nasty world,
their automatic response is to be selfish,
but then no matter where you start,
the more you think about it,
the more selfish you get.
So it's like deliberation undermines
whatever your automatic sort of heuristic
responses.
So almost in some ways pay,
perhaps he should deliberate less when
we think about cooperating with other
people.
Right. Which is a weird thing to be
saying because then, you know, in general,
I'm a big fan of deliberation.
Uh, you know, uh,
and I don't really think that in general
the world would be better off and
everybody deliberated less. Uh,
but that is the sort of, um,
basically the result of what we find is
that in these games you get better sort
of social.
So we're more socially beneficial
behavior when people deliberate less.
It's fascinating stuff. I mean,
you've also done some work,
I'm discovering that rewarding
interactions are actually as effective in
promoting group cooperation as punishment
and that these positive or rewarding
interactions may even
lead to better outcomes.
And so could you just tell us a little
bit about this because it's really
fascinating and also one of these results
that might be not what people exactly
expect.
Yeah. So the backdrop for that
work was that there's been,
in terms of the literature on cooperation,
on the evolution of cooperation and stuff
like that in the last maybe 10 or 15
years,
there's been this huge focus on basically
the reason people cooperate with each
other is that if they don't,
people will pay costs to punish others.
And so you should be a nice person or
like a well behaved person because if not,
other people will like really
make you suffer for it.
And like when I look around
the world that I live in,
I don't really see like a lot of like
spiteful or costly punishment where people
are going out of their way to impose
costs on other people as like a main
motivating force of most of
my social interaction. Uh,
um, but, uh,
and so what we were thinking
is that, um, you know,
I want to think about what do
I actually experienced in life.
It's not to say that people are just,
you can do whatever you want
and there's no consequences.
But it's that the main like vehicle for,
uh,
incentivizing good behavior,
I feel like is denial,
a future reward? And it's, we're
not talking about monetary rewards,
but if you think about things like,
um, okay, so the, the sort of the,
the little joke anecdote or did I tell
about this is, so if you think about, uh,
the sort of the cooperation problem being
a bunch of housemates living together
and like doing their dishes or not doing
their dishes as the case may be, uh,
that if it's just you're doing
dishes or you're not doing dishes,
as soon as one person stops doing their
dishes, everybody else is like, well,
screw it. I don't want to be the
person that's still doing my dishes.
And so like what the main body of work
in this field says is your solution
should be, is like when your
housemate doesn't do her dishes,
you should go into a room and smash a
laptop with a baseball bat and then she'll
do her dishes the next
time. And we're like, well,
maybe not a great idea,
but like what you can do instead.
That's that.
Is this denial,
a future reward kind of thing is like
next time say she comes and is like, hey,
you know, like I need help
with my of this math problem.
Can you help me with that? Can I borrow
your computer? Or something like that.
You're like, sorry, why don't you do
your dishes and then we'll talk about it.
So there's still,
it's still incentives,
but it's about rather than going out of
your way to do something destructive to
the person saying,
look,
I'm only willing to help you in the
context of our pairwise relationship if
you're being a good citizen at the group.
Well,
so that's nice in a way that it sort of
motivates people to be better citizens.
That they're more likely to get
cooperation from others if they behave
positively in a social context.
Exactly.
And so the way that you can explain a
lot of group level cooperation is by
remembering that the group interaction
doesn't happen in a vacuum,
but it happens super imposed on this
network. Personal relationships.
Excellent. So I want to ask
you a little bit, I mean,
what role do you think
emotion can play here? Um,
and thinking about some of the
stuff you've just talked about.
I think that,
uh,
a lot of what's going on with
the sort of automatic intuitive,
cooperative response is presumably,
uh, driven by emotion and affect.
Um, and so I think that that, uh,
emotions are probably a good,
um,
sort of proxy or tool for, for, uh,
communicating sort of general features
of the situation you're in and sort of
guiding your, uh, a little
bit more generalized responses
rather than, you know,
so if you think about this
in like a dual process, um,
respective of like these
automatic sort of generalized,
not very specific processes and then,
uh,
that are fast and then you wouldn't have
your slow controlled reason. Thank you.
Say, Oh, well, in this exact situation,
like what exactly should I be doing?
So I would see probably
a lot of emotions as a,
some of the somewhat more generalized
agents. I mean, it's not, that's not,
it's not to say that
they're completely general,
but that they respond to cues that aren't,
things that are like very
deliberation oriented.
Yeah,
that'll be fun.
I know you and I've had conversations
thinking about the role that maybe
positive emotions play
versus negative emotions.
And it seems like this is a wide open
territory to try to look into. Definitely.
So, you know, I'm thinking about this,
this is one of the other questions
about your research is that, you know,
this field of emotion and
cooperation is really exciting.
It's new and it's emerging.
And as part of that,
there's just a lot of unanswered
questions. Right. Um, and so,
you know, as an expert in cooperation, I,
I wonder what you think are
the most promising candidates
for emotion or related
processes to emotion that we could try
to really leverage to better understand
cooperation.
Yeah. So as you said, I think
there's a ton of candidates.
So the first thing that comes most
obviously to mind is empathy. Um,
that you know, that, Eh, if you,
the more empathic you feel
towards the other person,
the more inclined you are going to be,
uh,
to be cooperative from just like a
sort of, I don't know the right word,
but like a very direct kind of basic
thing. Okay. I unempathic I'll do it.
Then things that seem like,
uh,
it's maybe important for a little bit
more second order thing is our emotions.
Like pride. Like, you know,
you want to be a good person,
you feel sort of proud when,
you know,
when you help a stranger then you feel
actually, yeah, I really did write thing.
Like, that's good. You know, I feel good
about that. Or shame, you know, as the,
as the converse of that.
Um,
and then also when you get
into the domain of, um,
the reward and punishment kind
of stuff. So like, you know,
provisioning incentives,
it's trying to incentivize other
people to be cooperative. Uh,
presumably anger will be an important
motivation there. And also discussed.
I imagine it's something that
could be quite important.
Well, it will be really exciting to
see what some of these discoveries are.
I'm that you'll V sphere heading
in the years to come. Um,
so when you think about some of these
potential discoveries with the motion and
cooperation, you know, I know
that some people might wonder,
well is the role of emotion in cooperation
something that is a human universal
kind of cross culturally same everywhere
or might there be some important
sources of cross cultural variation here?
Yeah,
so I think that's,
it's such a fascinating question and it's
a direction that I'm really interested
in exploring. Um, cause
I think that there's,
there's good documentation
of cross cultural differences
in behavior in terms of
cooperation. And so I, what I think is,
is really interesting to me is to what
extent are those differences differences
because um,
this sort of mechanisms for getting
people to follow norms are the same.
And what varies across cultures are
the norms. So it could be, you know,
people feel proud when they follow the
norm. They feel shame when they don't,
they get angered when other people don't.
And it's basically when people don't
behave appropriately or do behave
appropriately.
And then what varies across cultures is
what's the definition of appropriate or
could it be that there are
actually deeper level, uh,
differences and that like doing
appropriate behavior triggers,
different emotional responses
in different places.
And I don't think anybody knows and I
think it would be very interesting to find
out.
So when you think about the face of
the future and think about emotion or
emotion in cooperation,
what do you see in store for the future?
Well, I think, like you were
saying a little bit earlier,
it's really like the wild
west that they're, you know,
there's like 10 million different awesome
things to do. Uh, so what, I mean,
the main thing that I see is
lots of cool papers coming out,
trying to actually pin down specific
relationships between particular emotions
or particular combinations of emotions
and behavior outputs in, in this context.
Yeah. And so what advice
would you have for students?
A lot of them will be spearheading
this wild west in the future.
What advice would you have
for these students? You know,
as they try to embark and studying
some of these questions that relate to
emotion?
MMM.
Yeah. Okay. What advice?
It's a good question. Uh,
okay.
I think that
one thing that I would say
is particularly important,
at least from my perspective.
So I really like using economic games
and I think that like economics offers a
lot of really good methodologies for
studying these kinds of questions.
And in particular,
I think it could be really fruitful for
people coming from psychology and from a
sort of an ocean perspective, uh,
that you can use these approaches, uh,
like a methodologies from economics in
combination with ways of thinking about
things and approaches from psychology
to get these really sort of productive,
synergistic interactions in a way that
people that are just doing econ would
never think to ask about
emotions in these kinds of way.
People that were just doing
emotion research using the
econ wouldn't have these
cool tools.
So I think that this is really a fruitful
place for integrating approaches.
And what I would say in pursuit of
that is if you're going to do it,
people should really try and understand
some behavioral economics. Um, and like,
I think there's a lot of people using it,
economic games without
really understanding the way
economists think about them.
And it would be worth understanding that
because there's some interesting stuff
there.
Well,
thanks so much for speaking with us today.
This concludes our expert in emotion
series with Dr. David ran from Yale
University.